von nun an wird facebook unter dem namen
meter bekannt sein es handelt sich aber
nur um eine namensänderung die
unternehmensstruktur bleibt mit der
ursprünglichen at familie erhalten
facebook messenger whatsapp und
instagram werden ihren namen beibehalten
und auf die gleiche weise funktionieren
auch das kürzel zum börsenticker wird
sich ändern und ab dem ersten dezember
auf meter verweisen es mag nur eine
namensänderung sein aber es ist bisher
facebooks größter schritt in die zukunft
und in richtung metaversum
diese riesige virtuelle welt in dem user
vor allem durch die verwendung des
opfers headsets eines virtual reality
oder auch augmented reality headsets
miteinander interagieren können wurde
auf der veranstaltung am donnerstag
angekündigt mark zuckerberg glaubt dass
das mit der version vor allem die
weltwirtschaft ankommen wird
innerhalb des nächsten jahrzehnts wird
es mehr als eine milliarde menschen
erreicht haben und über mehr als 100
milliarden dollar an digitalen handel
verführen es wird arbeitsplätze für
millionen von kreativen und entwickler
and schaffen
das unternehmen ist auf dem besten weg
im märz 20 21 einen umsatz von 120
milliarden dollar zu erzielen die
vorstellung dass das metaversum am ende
des jahrzehnts ein paar hundert
millionen dollar ausmachen wird lässt
erahnen wie weit der weg noch ist und
gibt uns ein gefühl dafür wie weit
facebook und deren technologie noch in
der entwicklung stehen
wir haben verschiedene anwendungsfälle
horizon plattform auf der sich nutzer in
der version bewegen erleben können es
ist nicht nur auf spiele beschränkt
obwohl neue titel und partnerschaften
auf der spielseite angekündigt worden
sondern es wurden auch anwendungen für
gesundheit und fitness für das ok des
headset vorgestellt in denen sich die
teilnehmer im virtuellen raum treffen es
gab auch anwendungen für den digitalen
handel bei denen geschäftstransaktionen
über virtuelle räume abgewickelt werden
mark zuckerberg meint es sei
umweltfreundlicher denn alle virtuellen
im metaversum abgewickelten geschäfte
sparen flüge und somit auch co2 der
bereich sonstiges und zahlungen machte
im dritten quartal dieses jahres 2 bis 3
prozent des umsatzes aus
meter hat noch einen weiten weg vor sich
hat aber seine investitionen bereits
verdoppelt die investitionsausgaben
werden wohl den geschäftsjahren 21 und
22 weiterhin stark ansteigen auch wird
will das geschäftsergebnisse mehr 2021
bereits um zehn milliarden dollar sinken
da facebook in reality apps investiert
hat was in zukunft ab q4 wohl ein
eigener posten für einnahmen sein wird
genau werden wir es wohl erst wissen wir
mit das geschäft wächst und das mit
diversen echte einnahmen und gewinn
verzeichnen
noch vor ein paar stunden haben sie bei
einem unternehmen namens facebook
gearbeitet jetzt heißt es meter sie
ändern sogar den börsenticker das hat
selbst google nicht getan die mehrheit
des unternehmens arbeitet noch gar nicht
im metaversum warum also dieses risiko
eingehen
nun wir sehen es nicht als risiko an
denn wir kommen ja von einem unternehmen
das bereits alle hände voll zu tun hatte
wir alle beim etat sind sehr aufgeregt
und blicken begeistert in die zukunft
die wir gemeinsam mit unserem
unternehmen gestalten wollen auch unsere
mission hat sich nicht geändert metas
fokus liegt zwar auf dem aufbau des
metaversum es aber auch weiterhin darauf
menschen miteinander zu verbinden
gemeinschaften zu bilden und unternehmen
in ihrem wachstum zu unterstützen so wie
wir es bei facebook bereits seit fast 20
jahren tun
es wurde zeit dieser riesigen familie an
apps einen eigenen namen zu geben denn
auch wenn alles mit facebook begann es
ist doch über die zeit gewachsen und der
name stand nun nicht mehr für eine app
sondern für eine ganze reihe von
einzigartigen apps wie whatsapp oder
instagram diese ganzen technologien
bringen wir nun unter einen namen einer
brandneuen unternehmensmarke zusammen
geben sie uns ein paar informationen
darüber wie der horizon marktplatz
aussehen wird wird er wie ein app store
funktionieren wird es ein abo modell
geben wie werden die menschen damit in
zukunft geld verdienen
eine menge fragen fangen wir bei horizon
an damit stellen wir den menschen eine
soziale plattform zur verfügung mit der
sie im metaversum kreieren und
interagieren können mit orson welles
können sie welten erschaffen indem sie
mit ihren freunden ihrer familie oder
ihren kolleginnen eintauchen und neue
orte entdecken können sie können sich
dort treffen spiele spielen oder
verschiedene mitglieder ihrer
gemeinschaft mit verschiedenen avatar
kennenlernen
horizon home ist unsere erste vision für
ein virtuelles zuhause im metaversum und
wird eine erweiterung zu den bereits
verfügbaren horizon workgroups sein erst
letzte woche war ich in einem virtuellen
meeting und das gefühl das man hat wenn
man zusammen an einem virtuellen tisch
sitzt ist ein ganz anderes besonders in
der heutigen zeit in der wir alle viel
online oder remote arbeiten man hat
tatsächlich das gefühl dass man zusammen
an einem tisch sitzt man dreht den kopf
und sieht seine kolleginnen es ist ein
ganz anderes publikum
es ist ein erweitertes soziales erlebnis
wenn man so will
was aber wenn das metaversum und wie all
die welt gar nicht sozialer machen wenn
sie uns isolierter und unsozialer machen
also viele dieser kritikpunkte mit den
facebook konfrontiert war
nun diese erfahrung habe ich persönlich
nicht gemacht als ich mich im virtuellen
raum mit leuten getroffen oder spiele
gespielt habe meine kolleginnen und ich
wir waren auf dem mond und haben self es
mit unseren avataren gemacht im
hintergrund waren die sonne und die
sterne zu sehen
ich denke aber dass der kern ihrer frage
darauf abzielt wie wir als firma
sicherstellen dass wir uns mit dem
metaversum dass wir bauen
verantwortungsvoll auseinandersetzen und
ich denke es gibt ein paar dinge die
besonders wichtig sind
erstens das metaversum wird nicht von
einem unternehmen allein erschaffen
viele verschiedene firmen eine menge
unterschiedlicher entwickler innen von
anderen unternehmen werden gemeinsam
daran arbeiten
auch ist es sehr wichtig von anfang an
grundsätze über die sicherheit um moral
einzubeziehen wenn wir die grundsätze
unserer gesellschaft auch hier
beherzigen können wir viel besser mit
den neuen herausforderungen umgehen die
unweigerlich mit den neuen technologien
entstehen werden
die facebook fans haben einige der
missstände in den sozialen medien
aufgedeckt facebook waren diese probleme
bekannt wurden aber aus sicht der
öffentlichkeit nicht streng genug
angegangen instagram zum beispiel ist
gerade für teenager sehr gefährlich nur
weniger als fünf prozent der
hasserfüllten inhalte wurden aber
tatsächlich entfernt stellt sich
facebook nun dieser wirklichkeit oder
ist es eher eine flucht verpflichtet
sich meter für diese probleme die
verantwortung zu übernehmen
wissen sie es wird gerade sehr
koordiniert versucht durch selektiv
veröffentlichte dokumente ein falsches
bild unseres unternehmens zu zeichnen
und das spiegelt wirklich in keiner
weise das unternehmen wieder das ich
kenne das mir am herzen liegt und für
das ich gerne arbeite ich bin wirklich
stolz darauf dass wir diese schweren
kompromisse die damit verbunden sind so
gut gemeistert haben
schauen sie sich die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen und die erheblichen
investitionen an die wir getätigt haben
wenn wir uns nur mal dieses jahr
anschauen wir haben mehr als fünf
milliarden dollar für die sicherheit
ausgegeben mehr als jedes andere
technologie-unternehmen auch wenn man
sich die größenordnung ansieht von der
wir sprechen wir beschäftigen heute mehr
als 40.000 mitarbeiter in allein für die
sicherheit des unternehmens
dies zeigt dass wir nicht weglaufen
sondern die verantwortung die wir hier
haben absolut ernst nehmen und diesen
fortschritt können sie in allen
bereichen unseres unternehmens sehen
aber es sind 40 tausend angestellte die
drei milliarden nutzer in betreuen ist
meter denn in der lage diese
herausforderung zu meistern
es mag ja sein dass es dort viele kluge
und fähige mitarbeiter in gibt aber
können sie jedes politische moralische
und religiöse thema auf der ganzen welt
und in jeder sprache bewältigen oder ist
das für jedes einzelne unternehmen
einfach schier unmöglich
unter anderem haben wir uns vorgenommen
unsere arbeit in diesem bereich sehr
offen und transparent zu halten aus
diesem grund veröffentlichen wir jetzt
vier mal im jahr den community standards
enforcement report und stellen ernst &
young unsere geschäftsberichte zur
verfügung damit diese in der lage sind
völlig unabhängig unsere ergebnisse zu
betrachten und zu validieren
darauf können wir wirklich stolz sein
denn ich denke dies ist eine der
umfassendsten und anspruchsvollsten
herausforderungen die wir derzeit
umsetzen aber um ihre frage zu
beantworten
wir können natürlich nicht zufrieden
sein wenn es auf unserer plattform etwas
gibt das in irgendeiner weise jemandem
schaden könnte wir werden uns also
weiterhin dafür einsetzen dass so etwas
von unserer plattform verschwindet wir
werden vielleicht nicht jeden schaden
verhindern können aber wir sind fest
entschlossen alles in unserer macht
stehende zu tun um solche fälle so
gering wie möglich zu halten im moment
ist facebooks werbeanzeigen geschäftjahr
der treibende motor für das wachstum in
der branche wir haben gesehen dass
facebook twitter und snap aufgrund der
änderungen der apple werbe tracking
technologie einbußen hinnehmen musste
nette gibt heute seine
geschäftsergebnisse bekannt und wie es
scheint haben sie ihre schätzungen für
das vierte quartal verfehlt als jemand
der so viel einfluss auf das werbe
anzeigen geschäft besitzt könnten sie
uns ein paar worte dazu sagen
wir haben schon lange vor apples ios 14
politik gewandt und vor der tatsache
dass sie in wirklichkeit den eigenen
gewinn auf kosten von urheberinnen und
kleineren unternehmen begünstigt hat und
wir sehen dass das jetzt der fall ist
vor allem kleinere unternehmen die über
sehr niedrige budgets verfügen müssen in
der lage sein ihre kundinnen die für sie
wichtig sind zu erreichen
und gerade im letzten jahr haben wir
gesehen wie wichtig dies für junge
unternehmen war die ihre läden nicht für
ihre kundinnen öffnen konnten im grunde
glauben wir dass datenschutz und werbung
weiterhin gut vereinbar sind auch ohne
den von apple verursachten
kollateralschaden
es kamen fragen zum absacker bergs
zukünftige rolle im unternehmen auf ich
bin gespannt ob es anzeichen dafür gibt
dass er als ceo zurücktritt um
vielleicht in den vorstand zu wechseln
wie es larry und sergej bei google getan
haben vielleicht gibt es auch
überlegungen das sharrow eine andere
rolle übernehmen wird oder einen schritt
zurücktreten wird wenn das werbe
anzeigen geschäft im metaversum jetzt
eher eine untergeordnete rolle spielt
niemand behauptet dass unser
werbeanzeigen geschäft in zukunft nicht
mehr so wichtig sein wird es ist
weiterhin ein wichtiger teil unseres
geschäfts und ich wünschte sie hätten
mag und scherrer auf der konferenz auf
der wir gerade präsentiert haben erleben
können die begeisterung die nicht nur
von sheryl sondern von allen unseren
führungskräften im unternehmen ausging
alle waren begeistert und hatten spaß
unsere vision der nächsten jahrzehnte zu
testen und zu teilen
nicola als jemand der so entscheidend am
globalen werbeanzeigen geschäft
beteiligt ist welche möglichkeiten für
zukünftige kampagnen sehen sie im
metaversum die effektiv wird ihrer
meinung nach das ad hoc ding dort seien
und wie glauben sie können
werbetreibende davon profitieren
ich denke dass es viele neue und
aufregende möglichkeiten für
werbetreibende im metaversum geben wird
es wird sich vieles und metaversum
weiterentwickeln sowie sich vieles heute
im internet weiter entwickelt aber die
art und weise mit der wir unsere
produkte und werbemöglichkeiten
entwickeln wird bleiben wir beginnen
beim menschen und stellen sicher dass
sie unsere produkte zu 100 prozent
verstehen und nutzen können
ich denke es wird eine menge
möglichkeiten für entwickler innen und
nutzer innen geben wir werden dafür
sorgen dass es genügend tools geben wird
damit man auch im metaversum erfolgreich
sein kann es gibt also viel worauf man
gespannt sein kann wir sehen bereits
unternehmen die anfang mit augmented
reality zu experimentieren ich denke da
zb an den virtuellen ravens tor der ist
einem auf instagram erlaubt
sonnenbrillen anzuprobieren oder der
shop von charlotte very in dem make-up
und lippenstifte ausprobiert werden
können
wir sehen also dass manche marken anfang
spaß daran zu haben
sie führen jeden tag eine menge
gespräche mit werbetreibenden deshalb
möchte ich sie fragen ob sie sich sorgen
um den ansteigenden rummel auf sozialen
medien machen machen sie sich sorgen
über zukünftige behauptungen oder
enthüllungen von whistleblowern wie zum
beispiel jetzt erst frances augen denn
die kritiker fragen sich natürlich ob
man werbung auf einer plattform wie
facebook heutzutage noch rechtfertigen
kann
ja also alle gespräche die ich mit
unserem partner in bisher führte waren
fundiert und gut durchdacht sie schätzen
unseren cleveren ansatz die
investitionen die wir tätigen und die
beträchtlichen fortschritte die wir im
laufe der jahre gemacht haben
sie erkennen sehr wohl wie information
aus dem zusammenhang gerissen werden und
warum es für ein unternehmen richtig ist
seine eigenen produkte zu analysieren um
sich ständig zu verbessern
unsere kundinnen verstehen dass das ein
wichtiger bestandteil unserer arbeit ist
und sehen auch unser engagement in
organisationen wie garn oder amnesty zu
der wie auch stehen
die moz de suisse
sie sind beeindruckt von mir dass
präsentationen oder
auf jeden fall und es ist natürlich auch
eine sehr ehrgeizige vision die sie
davor gestellt haben viele investorinnen
wird diese präsentation begeistert haben
solch eine vision von einem unternehmen
zu sehen das einen jahresumsatz von über
120 milliarden dollar besitzt
mark zuckerberg ist tatsächlich
innovativ und sehr visionär wenn es
darum geht sein unternehmen auf die
nächste stufe zu heben es wird auch sehr
schwer werden das alles umzusetzen
es wäre natürlich einfacher gewesen
diesen schritt in einem früheren stadium
zu wagen als facebook noch etwas jünger
war sie hat mir sehr erfolgreich vom
desktop aufs handy geschafft und dann
vom handy auf instagram aber die
skeptiker fragen sich natürlich wie sie
diese ganzen inhalte auf die plattformen
bringen wollen
für die demo hatten sie ja grand theft
orgel metaversum gezeigt aber das ist
nur ein spiel es geht ja darum ein
ganzes ökosystem aufzubauen und wirklich
alles im sinne der kreativwirtschaft
zusammenzubringen das ist für ein
erwachsenes unternehmen sehr viel
schwieriger wenn man außerdem mit einem
großen vertrauens problem zu kämpfen hat
und genau da sehe ich die
herausforderung aber man muss auch sehen
dass diese vision ja auf die nächsten
zehn jahre ab
schritt für schritt wird es möglich sein
kerngeschäft und transformationen zu
vereinbaren ich denke bei fast drei
milliarden nutzer ist das der richtige
weg
[Musik]
mandy ich glaube es weiß gott kessler
der verhinderer hingewiesen hat dass
facebook heute die marke mit den wohl
negativsten assoziationen der geschichte
ist soll uns meter von all den problemen
und dem negativen der vergangenheit
ablenken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wegen methoden zur nutzung von daten
konzentrieren dennoch sind sie immer
noch ein sehr innovatives unternehmen
was alles für die nächste große
technologie welt aber wie ich bereits
sagte denke ich dass die größte
herausforderung natürlich in der größe
des unternehmens liegt erst recht wenn
der fokus hier nun komplett auf das
medium verschoben wurde